THE STATE OF CARVANA:
Over the past 12 months,
Carvana stock is up 750% meaning that if you
invested $1,000 at the beginning of 2023, you’d
now have $8,500. Hearing this, you’d probably
be inclined to think that Carvana is killing it,
but if we zoom out a bit more, you’ll see a
completely different picture. Zooming out to 5
years, you’ll see that Carvana stock has actually
fallen off a cliff. From their peak in late 2021,
Carvana stock literally fell 99% by the end
of 2022 from $380 to $3.63. And even with
their massive rally over the past 12 months,
Carvana stock is still down nearly 90% from
the peak. Given all the market volatility,
high interest rates, and high inflation, it
would be easy to just write off this decline as a
stock that was hit hard by the macro environment,
but there’s a lot more to this story. From
registration and title issues to stolen cars
and thousands of complaints. During the worst
of it, Carvana’s annual losses ballooned to as
much as $1.58 billion. As such, Caravana’s decline
very much has to do with poor fundamentals as much
as it does with a poor macroeconomic environment.
But, it wasn’t always like this. Not too long ago,
Carvana was the startup super star that had
revolutionized the used car market. They had
made it easier than ever to sell and buy cars
all from the comfort of your phone without having
to deal with a single car salesman. That’s
why at their peak, Carvana was worth nearly
$70 billion. For perspective, that’s nearly as
much as Mercedes Benz, and the only automotive
companies that really outshine that number
is Toyota and Tesla. The good news, however,
is that not all is lost for Carvana. In fact,
Carvana has been staging one of the biggest
comebacks we’ve ever seen. They just posted their
first real quarterly profit of $782 million and
it seems that the nearly 10X stock recovery is
just the beginning. But, what about all of the
serious concerns regarding stolen cars and invalid
titles? Has that been resolved? Well, let’s find
out by taking a closer look the contoversial
rise, fall, and rise again of Carvana.
CONTROVERSIAL ORIGINS:
If you think that Carvana has had a controversial
past, just wait till you hear about the story of
the founders because it’s far more controversial.
Taking a look back, the story of Carvana takes us
back to a convicted felon named Ernest Garcia II.
Garcia the II came from a pretty well off family
in New Mexico. His father not only owned a liquor
store but he was the mayor of Gallup, New Mexico,
so safe to say that Gracia the II grew up with
some pretty powerful friends. And in classic
villain fashion, Garcia the II wouldn’t waste
anytime in leveraging these connections to enrich
himself which brings us into his first business:
real estate development. There’s obviously a
lot of money to be made with real estate but
Garcia the II would often find himself entangled
with shady deals. In October of 1990, for example,
Garcia the II would plead guilty to fraudulently
obtaining a $30 million line of credit while
simultaneously helping a local bank hide their
land ownership from regulators. This would earn
him 3 years of probation and his firm filing for
bankruptcy. Having burnt his reputation within the
real estate world, Garcia would make the jump
to an adjacent industry: car sales. In 1991,
he would purchase a bankrupt rent a car franchise
called Ugly Duckling for a $1 million. He didn’t
exactly know how to turn around the renting model,
so he would just turn the company into a used car
dealership that targetted subprime car buyers. To
be honest, Garcia wasn’t really in the business
of selling cars but rather handing out loans to
delinquent borrowers. In fact, as much as 45% of
their car loans are delinquent at any given time,
and they actually have 370 full time employees
to collect these overdue payments. Selling cars
to naive people that they can’t afford and then
ruthlessly collecting turned out to be a pretty
profitable business model. By the turn of the
century, the Ugly Duckling was a public company
with annual revenues of $600 million. At this
point, Garcia would decide to rebrand the company
in order move further away from his checkered past
leading to the new name: DriveTime Automotive,
you might’ve heard of it. DriveTime would go onto
earn billions of dollars every single year which
brings us into the next generation of Garcias:
Ernest Garcia III. Garcia the III would follow the
classic path of a rich kids son. He would attend
a prestigious university which in his case was
Stanford before coming back to join the family
business in 2007. Oftentimes, these kids are the
ones the run the family business into the ground,
but that wasn’t the case with Garcia the III. He
was determined to take the family business to a
wholenother stratosphere. He had grown up seeing
the rise of the internet and dotcom companies
like Amazon and eBay. He knew that people weren’t
quite ready to make massive purchases like cars
fully online just yet, but he speculated that
it was just a matter of time. And if anybody
had the resources, influence, and power to pull
this off, it was him. So, in 2012, with the full
backing of Drivetime, it’s executive team, and
his father, Garcia the III would launch Carvana.
CONTROVERSIAL SUCCESS:
With all of that context,
it’s really no surprise why Carvana went on to
be a massive success. Carvana was no ordinary
startup created by a couple of college students.
Carvana was a strategic and calculated extension
to an already massive family fortune. Drivetime,
or basically Garcia the II, provided Carvana,
or basically his son, with the cars he needed, the
financing he needed, the technology he needed, and
the expertise he needed. Technically, Garcia the
II isn’t one of Carvana’s directors or officers,
but don’t let that fool you. This was a strategic
move to keep Carvana separate from Garcia the II’s
past. And behind the scenes, the Garcia’s are not
only close but they literally live next to door to
each other. Not to mention, Garcia the II is still
the company’s largest shareholder with a stake of
roughly 25%. Also, the father son duo owns super
voting shares in Carvana which gives them full
control of the company. But, I think that’s enough
about the Garcia family because there’s plenty of
controversy to cover regarding Carvana itself.
It’s not that Carvana is a direct scam. If you
order a car, you will indeed get your car, and if
you a sell a car, you will indeed get your money.
But, there’s a lot more to buying and selling cars
than just transacting cash and authorizing loans,
and this is where Carvana really falls short. Over
the years, they’ve built up a habit of cutting
corners and turning a blind eye to everything
that doesn’t directly earn them money such as
quality. According to Carvana’s former employees,
“They’re not inspecting vehicles. They’re taking
cars in with frame damage and not inspecting the
frame damage. They’re selling you guys cars with
unreported accidents and cars with accidents that
haven’t shown up on the car facts yet. If you’re
out of the seven-day-money-back guarantee period,
you’re screwed.” Since these allegations came out,
Carvana has gone ahead and put out a bunch of
articles about how much they care about quality,
but you can take that for what you will. Another
concerning piece of evidence against Carvana is
their management of vehicle titles. Carvana’s
lead lawyer, Paul Breaux is facing a whopping
57 criminal charges in the state of Illinois. This
includes 27 counts of failure to transfer vehicle
titles and 50 counts of improper use of titling
and registration. Illinois would even go as far
as banning Carvana from the entire state on 2
separate occasions. And that’s just the tip of
the iceberg. Zooming out, Carvana was selling cars
with hit or miss quality, had a bunch of title and
registration issues, their lead lawyer was facing
dozens of criminal charges, they were facing
state wide bans, they were also facing a class
action lawsuit, they were selling stolen cars,
and they were getting thousands of complaints
through the better business bureau. If all of that
wasn’t bad enough, Carvana’s cars were usually
sold with super high markups. In Q1 of 2023,
for example, Carvana boasted a per car profit
margin of an astounding 61%. Why do people agree
to pay these ridiculous markups you ask? Well,
they’re usually just uninformed customers who are
sold the vision of convenience and not having to
deal with car salesmen, when in reality, it would
probably be in their best interest to haggle with
a car salesman than buy through Carvana. With all
of that being said, this is precisely the type
of company that you would want to avoid with
a 10 feet pole, yet Carvana would go onto have
the run of their lives thanks to the pandemic.
CONTROVERSIAL FALL:
The pandemic was basically the best
thing that could have ever happened to Carvana.
With everyone stuck at home and often scared to
go outside, buying a car completely online was a
more desirable option than ever. Combine this with
0% interest rates and massive stimulus checks, and
it wasn’t long before people were casually buying
cars from Carvana as if it were a $50 gadget you
ordered on whim from Amazon. Combine this with the
chip shortage which made it nearly impossible
to buy a new car in a timely manner, and used
car prices would skyrocket. In fact, for quite
a bit of 2022, you could’ve sold your existing
car for a higher price than you bought it for. As
such, revenue at Carvana would explode from $3.9
billion at the end of 2019 to nearly $15 billion
by mid 2022. Similarly, Carvana stock would rocket
1100% from the pandemic bottom transforming them
from a multi billion dollar company to a several
deca billion company. But eventually, the music
would stop playing for Carvana in mid 2022 as
Jerome Powell started jacking up rates. Given that
Carvana’s bread and butter was selling used cars
with massive price hikes to uninformed customers
who couldn’t really afford them, increasing
interest rates really took a toll on Carvana.
Combine this with the chip shortage finally
coming to an end and used car prices cooling down
substantially and Carvana would take a big hit on
revenue and an even bigger hit to profit which
brings us into Carvana’s single biggest issue:
burning money. Despite selling used cars at
far larger markups than virtually anyone else
in the industry, the reality was that Carvana was
never really profitable. It turns out that buying,
shipping, and selling cars across the United
States was an extremely expensive. Not to
mention, the hundreds of millions they were
spending on advertising per quarter. In fact,
this trend only got worse during the pandemic. As
their revenue ballooned, so did their losses which
peaked at just under $1.6 billion. Investors,
didn’t really mind these losses when revenue
was growing multiple fold and car sales were
through the roof, but when that narrative changed,
so did the sentiment around the stock. If
declining revenue and losses weren’t bad enough,
Carvana’s corner cutting over the past decade
would finally start coming to light almost in
unison. And just as all of that was happening
internally at Carvana, the entire stock market
would take a nosedive due to recessionary fears,
high inflation, and high interest rates. Strong
companies like Facebook and Netflix themselves
would crash 75%. So, it’s not surprising that
Carvana, someone with shaky fundamentals was
hit even harder. Though, it’s still crazy to
think that this led to a full 99% crash. Since
then, it’s not really clear how much of the stink
Carvana has really cleaned up. To be honest, it
doesn’t seem like they care to do much more than
what regulators and states are forcing them to do
in terms of providing a better service. However,
they have got their act together on the financial
side of things just recently posting their first
real profit in history of $782 million. And
this has been enough for a lot of investors
to buy back in. But, that doesn’t change that
if you’re shopping on Carvana, you should still
be more than a bit careful as this is the type of
company that you’re dealing with. Unlike Carvana,
a marketplace with a much more wholesome story is
Craigslist. Check out this video to learn more.